the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I got an interesting question in the
anonymous comment box and I want to see
how many other people agree with it the
comment when something like is
everything in this field of nuclear
science engineering computational in
nature because so far we pretty much
just thrown theory and simulations at
you we haven't done any experiments so
who shares this concern or wonder so one
two three four funky five yeah so
getting towards roughly half of you so I
can confidently answer no this is not a
purely computational field we just had
to get you just enough science and
physics so that you'd be able to
understand some of the lab activities
that we've got in store for you
one of whom my games here from the
nuclear reactor lab it's gonna be
helping you with actually two of them
he'll be helping with you
yeah well the bananas and the thing that
we dreamed up today so sure fill in what
I get wrong also Mike's gonna talk about
what we're going to do together which is
called naa
or nuclear activation analysis there are
many many ways of measuring what sort of
impurities may exist in materials and
this is among the most sensitive we
happen to have a nuclear reactor so what
we will be doing what I'm gonna ask each
of you guys to do for a special
assignment it's not graded except you'll
need it for the problem set so it kind
of is is I want each of you to bring
something into me that weighs about 50
milligrams in one piece fits in here is
not fissionable so if you have uranium
at home you know I shouldn't know about
it and we also ask that you don't bring
anything in that is too salty because
sodium activates like crazy and each of
you using your knowledge of radioactive
decay that we learned Tuesday and today
and the bateman equations and serious
radioactive decay next Tuesday and
Thursday are going to calculate what
impurities exist in your sample what is
your sample it's we're gonna make some
estimates of the isotopes that you'll
let us see the shorts yeah I know we're
not gonna get every impurity right
yes no but I will want your materials
next week okay so by Tuesday I'd like
each of you to come bring something in
for which you'd like to know the
elemental composition consisting of the
following elements let's see
problem sets I think I've got it right
up here let me just clone the screen so
you can see what we can look for so this
is provided to me by Mike we're gonna do
what's called a short nuclear activation
analysis run looking for any of the
elements up on this list shorts one with
extremely short half-lives and shorts
two with elements in the half-lives of
hours and Mike I had a question for you
now that we're live can we count arsenic
in that list because it's 24 points
something hours okay so if any of you
guys have some food that you bought
online and you don't know what sort of
contaminants there are or if you've got
a piece of your fingernail and want to
see if you are what you eat or what
about dog fingernails
okay so clip your pets claws if you want
to see if they are what they eat or
don't tell me what nail the thing came
from or you know get a you know slice up
a piece of a peanut or whatever your
favorite food is or if you want to see
if there are any metal dyes used in your
clothing cut out a little 50 milligram
square it'll be like a fashion statement
in an experiment at the same time right
so we ask that it's about 50 milligrams
it's got to fit in here it's got to be
not that salty and not fissionable and
we're going to pack a couple of these in
one of these rabbits these polyethylene
rabbits we call it those one because
everything in nuclear is named after
animals and farm implements for some
reason did I go over that with you guys
the first day of class barns shakes pigs
rabbits okay so a rabbit is a little
capsule oh you pop open or you screw it
open oh yeah there's like a square nut
at the top
just a little capsule that goes through
pneumatic tube kind of like the old bank
machines and it'll go firing into the
reactor sit there for a while and get
pneumatically sucked back out so that we
can calculate the activation and decay
of the isotopes within and a pig is just
a big heavy thing of lead where you keep
pieces of things that you are radiated
for shielding so if you notice the sort
of methodology theme here Farms pigs
rabbits barn shakes
anyone else' know any other farm ii
nuclear units
yeah or farming anything so the
detectors in NIF are called toads and
bullfrogs why is that
so they actually bullfrog stands for
something that's pretty cool okay yeah
oh yes the acronym for acronym as well
as what I study which is crud or choc
river unidentified deposits it's the
gunk that builds up on fuel rods well I
talked to a fellow from Chalk River who
took extreme offense to this detriment
in nuclear power plants being attributed
to his fine laboratory Oh see that would
work but they're not actually chromium
rich yeah cool so Mike do you want to
say anything else
[Music]
mostly doing experiments these guys oh
really
samples in this the easiest thing for me
to do without losing any of your samples
is after something gets raided in this
block and you probably can't see that
there's a little poly bag I'll dump your
sample into the poly bag so something
that's like one piece works the best
what I usually tell people is something
that you could pick up reasonably easily
with a pair of tweezers but that may
give you good size we know nothing
[Music]
yep the list is posted on the stellar
say yeah yeah yeah we'll see mostly
these light elements the guys with the
espera C's I don't see that well
interesting we found gallium in your dog
Claus or something yeah you know Mac
they seem only titanium vanadium those
are nice will come out nicely some of
the elements of generally more interest
down further down you know medium
chromium
those have longer half-life so I'm going
to see those um you probably do like a
five or ten minute irradiation
let it decay for a little while and then
do a couple of counts reactor we will be
there a fair bit so what do you usually
use naa for naa well the thing we've
been using it for lately a lot is
anything that's going to go in the core
of the reactor we want to analyze to see
if there's any surprise elements to see
how much cobalt is in my past in doing
naa was all environmental samples so we
did a lot of trace element heavy metal
chemistry sediments crude oil fly ash
you know and so we would measure that
whole stack elements cool that was my I
don't know I think that's enough you
want me back here next Tuesday or
Thursday you have to explain a little
bit more the specifics of the process
and if you guys could depends on when
you do them if it's early November then
yes
which you guys should see it's pretty
cool and while those samples are
counting I run another rap so you can
almost come anytime during the day while
I'm cool yeah thanks Mike so you heard
the charge bring me your dog claws your
head you know I browse your skin flakes
your scabs your food pieces oh yeah so
no hair staticy so don't bring us your
hair but bring us your skin flakes your
scabs your dog claws your food scraps
your don't tell them get creative it
doesn't have to be something that I said
as long as it's not fissionable or salty
[Music]
yeah but so let's figure it out by
Tuesday that way if we have to veto we
have a wild for you guys to find another
sample we'll see we'll see what we can
do thanks Mike so yeah so Mike's gonna
be helping us do some nuclear activation
analysis in an edition next week we're
going to be counting our big bag of
burnt bananas because now that you're
learning about radioactivity and this
when we go over activity and series
decay you'll have enough of the science
to understand to calculate how - what is
the radioactivity of one banana and to
do so we need like 500 bananas get
enough statistics so we'll be going to
the reactor for that we've also set it
up so that next week and the week after
words you guys are going to be
manipulating the power levels of the
reactor so you actually get to sit in
the control seat raise and lower the
control rods and watch the power of
reactor change in ways you probably
won't expect unless you're getting
operator training and all of that stuff
is going to be used in the lab
components of the problem sets so you
might guys might have noticed there was
some spin thoris cope thing on problems
at three radiation protection did not
want me taking smoke detectors apart and
giving them all to you because that's
distributing open radioactive radiation
sources and probably shouldn't do that
but we've got plenty of lab stuff for
you to do to see what is actually
hands-on in this field and if you do
want to know what else is hands-on I
have an experimental group and you're
always welcome to come see what we do
with the lab there usually isn't an
explosion happening but there's usually
something at a thousand to fifteen
hundred Celsius temperature blue uranium
fluoride salts you know nano Newton
forces extreme pressures or what have
you we do a lot of it so I wanted to
give a quick review of where we were in
radioactive decay last time I think we
left off somewhere around particle
physics telescope explodes was my
favorite BBC headline ever when we were
talking about we've already gone over
alpha decay we've gone over beta decay
we started talking about positron decay
and the neutrinos that come out of that
and this kamiokande detector that is set
up with lots of expensive photo tubes to
detect the cones of light left as
neutrinos pass faster than the speed of
light in water through water and then
there is my favorite headline and I
believe we made it up to the end of
positron annihilation spectroscopy or
ways that you can actually use positron
emission to look at the number and types
of atomic defects in crystalline
materials and yep that's where we left
off interested in pas lots of papers to
check out in the meantime let's look at
one of the competing mechanisms for
positron emission which is electron
capture in this case so I will warn you
it's sometimes a little easy to get
mixed up between electron capture
internal conversion isomeric transition
so I've left these slides on here and I
also took pictures of the board from
last time and posted them on the stellar
site
so all the blackboards where we filled
the board's there's pictures of those
and I want to keep doing that so if
you've learned better just by looking
and listening rather than writing
everything feel free if you want to
write stuff down also feel free so an
electron capture another way of well
destroying positive charge would be for
the nucleus to capture an electron so
either it can emit a positron giving
away some positive charge or it can
capture an electron destroying one of
the positive charges and these case here
we've got a proton that becomes a
neutron and a something I won't be
specific as to which one because
positron and electron capture well two
different but similar kind of decay
mechanisms and then what you get is this
hole where the electron used to be and
that's not a very stable configuration
for an atom to have let's say one fewer
electron than protons and especially to
have a hole in the inner shell so you
get this cascade from straight up from
high school chemistry of electrons
falling from one shell to the next and
giving off characteristic x-rays that's
me that crossed that out there because
you will find misinformation all over
the place online and someone might make
a great figure and mislabel an electron
emitted photon as a gamma ray and
remember we said game has come from the
nucleus otherwise they're
indistinguishable photons and so an
electron captured you don't need much of
an energy difference between the parents
and the daughters unlike positron decay
where for positron decay to happen you
have to have Q at least equal to 1.0 to
2 MeV which is the same as 2 times the
rest mass of the electron for electron
capture you don't this can happen at
just about any energy as long as you can
overcome just the binding energy of the
electron which is negligible compared to
these sort of nuclear energy levels and
so this is the Q equation keep in mind
these deltas here are excess masses so
I'll put this up again the excess mass
is the real mass minus the terrible
approximation of a nucleoid mass and
this way excess mass and real mass are
directly related so you could plug in
masses here you could plug in binding
jeez by making everything with a minus
sign and so on I think I've repeated
myself enough for the Q equation stuff
would you guys agree yeah okay and so
these are actually two competing
mechanisms so shown here is the decay of
sodium 22 which we don't want to happen
in our nuclear activation analysis
because it gets pretty toasty
it can either proceed there's a kind of
hidden part of the diagram that I drew
in to make a little more sense you start
off with a nucleus at 2 point 8 MeV
above the neon nucleuses energy level
you need 1.0 to 2 MeV to create the
positron electron pair at which point
you can emit the positron with a certain
energy you're left at an excited state
and the next thing we'll go over is
gamma decay your isomeric transitions or
i.t
that's the next method of decay we'll
talk about or the nucleus can just
capture an electron getting to that same
energy level and emitting the same gamma
ray so these are two competing
mechanisms of decay and then you might
ask well when is one gonna happen and
not the other well chances are the lower
energy that transition is the more
likely a electron capture is going to
happen so when you look at these energy
diagrams you can see that as the
transitions get bigger the probability
of positron decay goes up and up and up
so you need 1.0 to 2 MeV to make the
positron and electron but the
probability of positron decay very close
to this is far is fairly low possible
but unlikely is everyone clear on these
two competing mechanisms so one way of
reducing the number of protons is emit a
positron another is gobble up an
electron in the end they make the same
daughter products but they go by
different mechanisms and they give off
different bits of radiation which we can
actually sense and measure cool so onto
gamma decay or isomeric transition these
range from the dead simple like
technetium-99 metastable giving off a
characteristic 140 ke V gamma ray for
technetium that's the medical imaging
procedure
we've talked a lot about to the
ridiculously complex like americium-241
which has a lot a lot a lot of different
nuclear energy states all of which
release anywhere between one and a lot
of gamma rays and this is what's
referred to as
isomeric transition so we'll say gamma
or isomeric transition is like the same
thing they're just different words for
it these are called isomers they've got
the same number of protons and neutrons
so it's the same nuclide but at an
excited state and we call it gamma decay
because we emit gamma rays or photons I
think this one is the easiest one to
understand because the reaction goes
something like let's say we have a
parent nucleus with Z protons and a
neutrons nothing happens it's about the
easiest nuclear reaction there is except
you do give off a gamma ray and we'll
usually put a star or something to
denote an excited state so when you see
a star in the reading over there on a
nuclide where the charge would be that's
an excited energy state that will likely
decay by i.t or gamma decay there is
also a competing mechanism for isomeric
transition or gamma decay and that's
what's called internal conversion in
this case you can kind of think of it
this isn't the correct physical
explanation but it's a perfectly good
mental model that the gamma ray I would
either just be emitted from the nucleus
at which point you would see it and the
energy of the gamma is the same as that
Q or it kind of hits an electron on its
way out
ejecting that electron so instead of
finding a gamma ray you may just get an
electron emitted at an energy very very
close to that gamma ray the difference
between the gamma ray energy and the
electron energy is it's binding energy
because if a gamma hits an electron on
the way out it has to overcome the
binding energy of that electron at which
point the rest of the energy is just its
kinetic energy so again
I don't think that's the precise
physical mechanism but it's a perfectly
good mental model to remember what this
is a gamma can either just get out on
its own or it can hit an electron on its
way out if you hit the electron on your
way out just like an electron capture
then you get a large larger shell
electron falling down to the inner shell
emitting an x-ray just like before and
then there's one other process I want
you guys to be aware of has anyone here
here ever heard of oj electron emission
or yeah so in this case instead of
sending out an x-ray you can think of it
like the x-ray kind of hits the another
electron on its way out
that's not the actual process that
happens but let's just think of it like
that and then that electron is ejected
usually from a much outer shell and we
can actually use these ój electrons
because they have specific but very low
binding energies to do imaging and
elemental analysis of materials so this
is another one of those things where the
stuff you're learning today is used in
an ogee electron microscope up in
building 13 to do combined imaging and
elemental analysis of materials I want
to skip back a sec because let's say we
have this decay diagram right here a
pretty simple one cesium 137 that
isotope that everyone was worried about
from the release from Fukushima can
either proceed by just beta decay or
beta decay followed by an isomeric
transition and shown here as a spectrum
of all the different electron energies
that you'll get out if you remember from
last time when we talked about let's say
the energy of a beta particle emitted
versus let's say the number of those
particles emitted if this is the Q value
for that reaction you don't always get a
beta particle out at the Q value in fact
you never do it looks something like
this where they'll be some let's say
average or some most likely beta energy
which is about
one third queue depends on the reaction
but that's a good rule of thumb so if
you've got a 1.1 74 MeV beta particle
you're gonna see a spectrum of electron
energies ranging from zero to one point
one seven four and you've got this other
beta transition possible at about half
an MeV so you're gonna see that same
spectrum right there and then there's
these two what's called the conversion
electrons that's evidence of the
competing process with gamma decay which
is to say that this gamma decay can
either just get out at which point you
see a gamma ray of that energy or that
gamma hits an electron on its way out
knocking those electrons out does anyone
know here what it means by K shell or L
shell if you do just shout it out so
that there depends on the that's correct
it's it's the energy level so let's say
we'll draw a kind of a Bohr model of a
nucleus we'll call it N and let's give
it three electron energy levels and
let's say there's a couple electrons in
the first shell and some electrons and
the outer shells and let's say this
electron was struck on its way out by a
gamma ray so it's gone at this point you
might have an electron fall from let's
call this level two to level one and so
this two to one transition is called the
K transition don't ask me why the
letters are the way they are I probably
have read it and have forgotten it
because it wasn't that intuitive but
this is referred to as a K transition so
you may have what's called the K alpha
or a K beta line that depends on if you
have an even higher energy shell but
whatever this letter is it tells you
what energy level the electron is going
to so the K lines would be here the L
line yeah I'm sorry let me let me back
up and say that again so the idea here
is that if this is the
let's see which one is this point six
six two so if the gamma-ray is at point
six six 2 MeV which would be about there
notice that these cash L and L shell
lines aren't quite point six six two
that's because they have to overcome the
binding energy of the electron to get
out so to jump back to this diagram
right here the gamma ray loses a little
bit of energy in freeing the electron
the rest of which can become kinetic
energy which is why you can see that the
electron let's say was ejected from the
K shell here and yeah I will I will say
that internal conversion you can imagine
a mental model of the gamma ray hits an
electron on its way out physically it's
more complicated yes yeah yep so if you
want to remember like what's what I
would say just remember this diagram
right here yeah Kristin just you'd you
get just the electron good question is
the gamma rays effectively absorbed in
freeing the electron from its bound
shell and then imparting kinetic energy
yep
that's right so that's correct
so we'll I'll spend the next couple
slides going over what O'Shea electron
emission is but not till we finish the
the easier stuff because OJ's a little
complicated did I see another question
out here cool so again all the competing
methods for a gamma decay won the game
it can just get out to the gamma can
knock out an electron from let's say the
K shell or the L shell or the M shell
and so on and so on depending on what
elements you have so I'll just label
these like this would be like the K
shell would be the L shell this would be
the M shell now I want you to notice
something to the K shell electron
ejected from the innermost electron is
slightly lower than the L shell electron
why do you guys think that is well let's
let's look at the energetics for this
process right the electron energy level
is whatever the gamma ray level is minus
the binding energy which of these two
electrons that the K shell or the L
shell do you think is going to be more
tightly bound the K shell the innermost
electron is more bound so it takes away
more energy from that gamma ray let's
say this is the gamma it takes more
energy to eject an electron from the K
shell than the L shell or in other words
the gamma loses less energy ejecting a
less bound electron so that's why you
see these if there were an M shell there
I don't know what element this was drawn
for but let's say o for cesium so there
probably is an M shell it's just that as
you get down in energy levels the
probability of finding an electron from
these outer and outer energy levels gets
way in way less likely
so you'd usually just see a K or an L
shell electron and if I ask you to draw
one of these on a problem set or an exam
just drawing the K and the L shells is
perfectly sufficient because that way at
least you'll know that there's a couple
possibilities yeah
on this one so these two curves
represent the probability of finding an
electron emitted at that energy so this
curve right here where you get a maximum
beta energy of 512 ke V comes from that
beta decay and the maximum for the 1.17
4 comes from this beta decay so the
total curve would be the sum of each of
these 4 things if I just said draw the
total probability of detecting an
electron at that temperature you just
add those up I saw two other questions
or were they the same thing yeah
ah so that so the question was is the
area under each of these curves one not
with this scale here we're just showing
a relative number of electrons so if you
want to find what's the total
probability that CCM will emit an
electron of each energy if you integrate
under all of these curves that will sum
to one if you're looking at just one of
these decays and you're saying if cesium
undergoes this decay what's the
probability of each of these energy
levels then you only integrate under the
relevant curve
what's more practical is usually what's
the probability of finding any electron
at any energy from cesium then you take
into account all the possible decays
draw all the curves independently add
them up and you get the total
probability function whose area will be
one yes
what can you say the last part again
that's correct so the L shell electron
in the second shell is less tightly
bound than the first one which is why
it's ejected with more energy it doesn't
take as much of the game as energy to
get it out if you were to get let's say
the outermost electrons ejected which
happens in O'Shay which we'll go over
next it can take up anywhere from like
one to seven
evie really really low energies that's
what we call the work function or the
the energy required to iron to take the
outermost electron out so any other
questions on this before I go to Jose
and show you that process cool so then
let's get into what is Jose electron
emission it's exactly luca's of what you
said you're asking about it yeah so it's
exactly like what Luke said normally if
you have a hole in a lower level energy
shell an electron from a higher shell
will fall down to fill it meaning an
x-ray a competing process for this is
another electron from a very similar
energy shell will get ejected instead
the mental model for this which again is
not the true physical picture but it's
perfectly fine to think of it like this
the x-ray hits another electron on its
way out and you can look at the
energetics accordingly where for Jose
emission let's say the kinetic energy
the Jose electron is the difference in
the final and initial electron energy
States minus the binding energy of the
Jose electron which will usually be very
low because the Jose electron that's
emitted is usually one of the outer
shell electrons so to help make this a
little more concrete I wanted to show
will do a little calculation example
it's just addition so it's not that hard
so let's say we were measuring I don't
even know what this is and we started to
see some characteristic Jose electrons
for a copper platinum carbon and oxygen
and the question is why do we see oxygen
coming out right there at about 501 easy
very very low energy compared to what
we've been talking about
we can actually look at the binding
energies of some of the different
electrons in oxygen luckily there aren't
that many electrons in oxygen
the first the only will the only k
electrons let's say have a binding
energy of 532 Eevee the l1 is 24 and
then the l3 something else and one of
the other P orbitals is 70 V and so the
formula is pretty simple it's just 532
minus 24 that's the difference between
the final and initial energy levels -
the seven - free that outer electron
comes to 501 evey which is exactly where
you see the oj line for oxygen so when I
ask you what are all the possible things
that you could see during the decay of
something something something if I were
to show you this curve and ask you
what's missing what would you do
where would you draw the oj electrons on
this curve yep yep 500 evey would be
like I don't know one pixel away on this
graph but if you want a complete answer
to this question you've got to take into
account all the possible beta energies
for all the possible beta decay
mechanisms all of the possible
conversion electrons for whatever gammas
come out in this case there's only one
gamma and oj electrons which could
compete with x-ray emission so everyone
clear on that
yeah
you
so the question is if you if you eject
an electron from one of the inner shells
does that eventually create a no J
electron right
it can these are competing processes so
either the x-ray can just escape during
that transition or will assume that it
hits another electron on its way out and
emits a no J electron so these are also
competing processes so you'll see one or
the other in reality you'll see a lot of
both with different probabilities
because they're usually not looking at
one atom it's usually looking at a lot
cool any other questions on i.t as an
isomeric transition or internal
conversion or Oh J what this is all
about who wanted to give you one note to
that these Oh J electrons are really
really low energy which means the only
ones that get out of the material are in
the top like tens or so of nanometers of
the material so it's a very surface
sensitive technique so if you want to do
really detailed surface analysis or
profiling you can scan an electron beam
across the sample and then collect the
o'shea electrons that come out skipping
ahead our calculation and get like an
elemental profile that'll tell you how
much of each element is where depending
on how many of its Oh J electrons you
can count and it's pretty it's a pretty
cool technique they're just machines
that do this now any interest in seeing
one of these at the Center for material
science and engineering because we could
try to arrange that - cool okay I'll see
what I can do that'd be fun and the last
decay that we haven't talked about and
did not show up in our generalized decay
diagram from last time we did talk about
Neutron decay there's one other one that
probably wouldn't fit on this diagrams
anyone know what it is spontaneous
fission so this can tap that's right
this happens with very heavy elements
then usually the heavier it is or the
less stable it is the higher probability
this is at which the nucleus can once in
a while it nuclei just explodes
sometimes giving off to fission products
any
number of neutrons usually between one
and three a couple of gamma-rays some
anti neutrinos and a whole bunch of
other craziness and so that of course
doesn't fit on the diagram but it is
another type of decay that I'll ask you
guys to analyze on the homework and
here's a hint you already analyzed part
of it in problem set one I'll ask you to
go a little deeper in problem set three
so anyone have a question I saw okay
bear with me because I skipped back to
like slide really far away oh cool
actually works right to the summary so
in summary the radioactive decay
processes are more I think the
energetics are pretty easy the formulas
aren't that hard to remember because
most of them are just parents -
daughters - something and what I do want
you to remember is which mechanisms
compete with which other ones and why
and if I were to tell you draw me a
spectrum of photons that you may see
from the decay of caesium-137 or draw me
a spectrum of electrons you'd be able to
draw what that is so that when you go do
lap number 4 and we count our big bag of
burnt bananas and you know that there's
potassium-40 in there you know what
Peaks to start looking for because
you're not just going to see looks let's
let's do a little flash-forward two
detectors now and some other stuff that
nuclear engineers actually do on a daily
basis let's say you're counting the
energy of photons as a function of let's
say the number of photons that you count
you're never you're almost never just
going to see a lone potassium-40
peak like that it's very very rare that
you would just capture the gamma ray as
is there's gonna be a lot of other
things that will go into it which I'm
not going to give away yet because we're
gonna go over photon interactions in
like a week or two but you do have to
think about well what other x-rays might
you see what if the gamma what if this
gamma ray hits an electron on the way
out and then you end up with some x-rays
let's say you might have some K level
x-rays and some L level x-rays and maybe
some M s these could all be possible as
well
I'll just label those real quick does
anyone know how to find these energies
what those x-ray levels are anyone ever
heard of the Lyman series the emission
lines from ionized hydrogen or anything
like that that's kind of the the simpler
case of it the idea here is if you want
to figure out what's the wavelength of
light that's going to be emitted it'll
be that's this thing called the Rydberg
constant a more complex formula for
which I have in the notes times one over
your final shell squared minus one over
your initial shell squared so the idea
here is that you can look up these this
Rydberg constant for any element that
you have and there's actually there's
what's called an R infinity constant and
I think you just multiplied by Z I
forget what power it is but I will get
it for you next time and then it's just
a matter of the squares between the
final and the initial shell levels where
n can vary from one to theoretically
infinity realistically I've never heard
of anything beyond a G orbital so let's
just say it's that or something like
that
oh but they'll all leave the Infinity
there that's technically correct okay
and so all you need to do is either look
up or calculate this constant for your
element and then plug in the numbers of
the shells and you know what sort of
photon energy you're going to get out
and to make that easier for you I think
now is a good time to introduce the NIST
x-ray tables so I want to make sure you
can see my screen and I'm going to show
you something that's on the stellar site
which will help you figure this stuff
out
22:01 good you can see probably will
make me login
and all the way at the bottom of the
material section there's the nist x-ray
transition energy database so for
example you can look at I don't know we
were looking at cesium right let's find
cesium and you can start to look at all
transitions let's look at the simplest
one KL one an electron going from shell
number two - shell number one get
transitions and you end up with a table
of these energies in electron volts so
if I were to ask you let's say what sort
of gamma rays might you see coming off
of cesium that would be the most likely
one where you're more likely to eject an
inner shell electron and it's most
likely that a number two shell electron
will fall down to a number one or from
the L shell to the K shell whatever you
want to call it or the some level
orbitals some other lows there seems to
be like eight different letters have
described the same thing I hope you guys
get the idea if you want to look at all
the possible transitions I have to zoom
back out again yeah let's just scroll
through it but what I want you to notice
is that all of the KL transitions are
within like a couple hundred Evie from
each other so this is like the first or
second or third L shell electron falling
to the K level so they call it the KL
one KL - KL three they're all from the L
shell they all just might be one of the
different electrons occupying that shell
which is why they're not that different
so if I asked you draw all of the all of
the x-rays and gamma is coming out I
don't want to see a line for every
single level I'm very happy for you just
to say this line represents the KL
series this line represents the km
series all the things from shell 3 to
shell 1 notice also that because it's
final minus initial squared which I
covered up falling from an even further
outer shell to the same inner shell
should give you a higher energy which it
does by like five ke V and then the KN
levels another 500 evie up they don't
have Kos interesting but they have the K
edge does anyone know what the K edges
exactly it's it's level infinity which
would mean an electron from somewhere
else right so this in effect is like the
energy it takes to ionize a K electron
or the x-ray that you would get from an
electron falling all the way into the K
shell so this is your kind of level
infinity notice that's not that
different from level 5 that's why I
wrote 6 I erased it for theoretical
correctness but in prom practicality you
won't see much else someone have a
question that I saw hand ok let's look
at the L Series oh yes yep yeah that's
another exactly yep there's the L alphas
the albedo's or you may see L alpha 1
and 2 and L beta 1 & 2 so L designates
that it's going to shell level 2 alpha
or beta is like LM or L n again I I
think I've ranted about notations before
physics is notorious because whoever
does that student and gets enough people
to in fact with the notation that you
decide it sticks but the main patterns
to look at then there's let's say the L
1 M whatever this is from level 3 to
level 2 notice how much lower and energy
these are and the L edge 5kv compared to
like 36 KETV and all of these are two
different transitions you can calculate
with this formula so this is just kind
of tabulated this formula for you so
whatever you're more comfortable doing
is putting this in Excel look it up on
NIST your choice yep
Oh what is the largest enough you mean
yeah for that I'll put my practical
thing back there you'll never see it
much higher than six unless you're
talking about actinides and super heavy
elements with even crazier shell levels
but you'll put the integer shell number
regardless of whether they call it L or
s or whatever they put the number here
and that will give you the a pretty good
approximation of the energy transition
does anyone remember this from high
school I hope they're teaching this now
well they did in five eleven one oh
that's good to hear what about three oh
nine one anyone take that no one took
four you're nine one Wow okay usually
it's like half and half raised oh cool
and let's see how far does it go all the
way to the L 3 ends in the L 3 edge so
that's the biggest element they have
talking about ridiculous transitions
yeah so notice also as you go up in
that's that that's number a hundred so
this is the heaviest one they have so
most likely to have the largest number
of levels so here the KL one is like 114
ke V sometimes indistinguishable from
some of these smaller nuclear energy
level transitions so remember I said
before chemistry and nuclear differ by
about a factor of a million well not so
if you're talking about weak gammas
versus heavy elements K shell
transitions or their K edges let's see
the Lea the largest X rayed expect would
be the K edge at a hundred and forty two
ke V and the technetium-99 gamma ray
comes out of one hundred forty KETV how
do you know if it's a game or an x-ray
you don't unless you have really really
good energy resolution and you can tell
them apart yep
correct
this thing's get quantum so the question
was this formula in this chart yes this
is only for x-rays and electron shells
there are probably equivalent
calculations for nuclear energy levels I
will say that's a 22:02 and far beyond
topic for the nuclear energy levels just
use the decay diagrams to find those
yeah the object the table of nuclides
and all there are different diagrams
cool how far do we go here L and yep
there's no OHS so they never talk about
anything beyond shell level for even for
fermium so huh I stand corrected okay
cool
so what I wanted to show you quickly is
is that series of hydrogen emission
lines so how familiar does this look to
folks where you can have a transition
from level 3 to level 2 level 4 to level
2 and you can actually this is a kind of
neat thing to verify I don't have it as
a problem set question because it's not
very nuclear but you can try this on
your own and verify that you can
actually calculate the expected
wavelength of these photons coming off
of excited hydrogen also notice here it
goes all the way out to 9 and out to
infinity because this is electronic
excitation you won't usually get the
ejection of anything beyond an M or an N
electron even in the largest elements
from let's say from I see what is it
from internal conversion but you can
electronically excite them to whatever
energy level to the point of even
ionizing them that's what the Infinity
comes in cool so it's like two of five
of so I want to open this up to any
questions about decay before we move
upstairs to talk about activity
half-life and series radioactive decay
which is what nuclear activation
analysis is all about so anything here
yep correct in our pre in in our other
notation this would be known as an LM
electron and probably l1 m1 because
there's only one electron in hydrogen
yep so don't let the notations trip you
up as long as you've I'm sure someone's
got a chart of L you know l equals two
equals whatever other Greek letter
someone has designated it for there's
just different ways of saying the same
thing so as long as you know the physics
looking up the notation is just kind of
a little pain any other questions on
radioactive decay or competing
mechanisms cool let's take a 10-minute
break so I'll see you guys upstairs in
room 307 in ten minutes
there's no projector there so we'll do
it all on the board all right so I want
to start off the second half of today's
class by posing and answering a question
who's still mentally having trouble
grasping this idea what did I tell you
yeah so whoever I said it to I said at
least half the class is right there with
you it's true so in a sentence it's this
Q is the conversion of mass to energy
that's all and the whole point of doing
this nuclear reaction energetics to find
out if things are aren't allowed if
they're x over endothermic is to see how
much mass is converted to energy or how
much energy has to be converted to mass
and if you have trouble remembering just
go back to the equation that I see on
everybody's t-shirts and like I said on
the first day of class everyone's got it
on their shirts and no one quite
understands it not even the nuclear
engineers because it's very difficult
mentally to grasp the idea that energy
and matter are two sides of the same
coin or two different forms of the same
thing so for a nuclear reaction where Q
is greater than zero or exothermic all
that means is that energy is
spontaneously created from the
destruction of mass that's all
and for aq less than zero reaction or
endothermic when you inject energy into
the system it is absorbed and mass is
created straight from this equation so
does this make more sense to the folks
that raised their hands which was almost
everybody Q is nothing but a
quantification of the amount of matter
and energy that turned from one to the
other and all the balanced stuff we'd
been doing for almost the last month has
been to conserve to quantify and to
predict it so hope that helps I know
that MIT students have this gift for
being able to hide behind the math and I
know that's true because I used to be
one myself and you could get through the
day or get through the class getting the
math right without really understanding
the physics or the mechanism behind
what's going on so everything we've done
for the last three weeks can be summed
up in one sentence mass and energy of
the same thing
we've just had a lot of math to get
there and be able to yeah it still kind
of makes your head want to explode right
do you think about it if you make a net
we want to make an endothermic reaction
happen you have to put kinetic energy
into one of the particles and that
system in the just barely allowed state
the nuclei won't really be moving or at
least the set yeah the nuclei won't
really be moving afterwards because
you'll have turned energy into matter so
that kinetic Energy's turned into mass
energy just like you can turn potential
into kinetic or thermal into mechanical
or vice-versa it's other forms of energy
kind of mind-blowing well anyways so now
that we finished radioactive decay I
want to get into the concept of activity
half-life and then we're gonna start but
not finish cereal radioactive creation
and destruction in your readings you'll
see an equation that looks something
like this
where we're gonna be at the end of the
day today if you want to show off how
much of some isotope and one exists as a
function of time you may have seen
something that looks like this we're
going to be able to understand how these
equations are created and because this
is MIT we're going to take it further
and add specifically driven mechanisms
like can you create an isotope not just
by decay from one isotope to another but
by intentionally making it which is
exactly how naa or nuclear activation
analysis works you fire neutrons into a
material they turn into something else
and start decaying in series this is
what we're going to be working out the
math for but I want to make sure it
every step that we get the physics right
so first a very quick primer on where
what what is activity and where does
half-life come from so we define the a
the activity of a substance as pretty
simple it depends on the amount of the
substance that's there and it depends on
what's called this decay constant so
this amount let's just say like atoms
and this decay constant is in units of 1
over second an activity is in let's say
atoms destroyed or decays for a second
that thing right there is called the
decay constant lambda and if we want to
see let's say how much of a substance is
decaying at a certain time or what's its
activity and get a measure of how
quickly does it take to decay away we
can start by saying well this in effect
is a destruction rate of isotope n so we
can make the simplest of differential
equations and say the amount of
substance n is a function of time is
just - its activity which equals minus
lambda n
I hope I don't have to explain how to
excel this differential equation so I'm
going to go through it pretty quickly
what's the method you use for this to
get n as a function of T yes you're all
in 1803 or have finished 1803 right this
should have been day one so we'll just
separate variables divide each side by n
multiplied it side by DT so we get DN
over N equals negative lambda DT you can
integrate both sides and we get the
natural log of n equals minus lambda T
plus some integration constant we're
gonna do a little bit of trickery and to
make things in a nice form that we can
deal with let's just call this log of
and not they're just numbers right we
haven't defined what this constant of
integration is every one clue cool with
us doing that so then we can subtract
log of n naught from each side and we
get log n minus log of n naught equals
minus lambda T so this is like saying
log of n over N naught equals minus
lambda T well take e to the power of
both sides and we get n over N naught
equals e to the minus lambda T and right
there you've got your exponential decay
equation this is the easy part and what
this tells you is it is a larger decay
constant well let me ask you a question
then what a larger decay constant mean a
faster or a slower decaying isotope a
larger decay constant correct means that
you've got more of these decays
happening per second so a larger lambda
means faster decay
and we also can define a quantity called
the half-life which means n at T 1/2
equals 1/2 and not so forth at all you
have to do is plug in T 1/2 for T and
1/2 and not for n naught and you
actually get this relation where the
half-life is just log of 2 over lambda
better known as 0.693 but we'll just
leave it as log of 2 for exactness and
that's all there really is for decay in
half-life so I'll told another question
to you something with a larger decay
constant will it have a larger or a
smaller half-life smaller because
they're inversely related
so I'd say from this quick derivation
these are the two things to note is that
something with a larger decay constant
decays faster and therefore has a
shorter half-life so when we were
separating out our isotopes in nuclear
activation analysis into what might call
the shorts and the lungs
he was separating them by half-life to
say that left fer let's say the same
amount of activation or the same amount
of creation the ones with shorter
half-lives will be hotter more
radioactive but for less time and so
what we're gonna be doing is what's
called short nuclear activation analysis
because we don't want to count for like
days or weeks or months yep the decay
constant is a property of the given
isotope specific to that type of decay
so if we were to draw that generalized
radioactivity diagram let's say we have
potassium-40
which can either go by beta decay to
what comes in beta what comes after
I think it's calcium for T or it can go
by positron or electron capture
to argon-40 each of these processes has
a different half-life and then in that
chain remember let's let's do the
americium-241 and I'm gonna channel my
one-year-old son and drawing this decay
diagram looks something like that with
all sorts of transitions I didn't scream
like he usually does but you know
whatever we're on camera
each of these decay each of these
transitions may also have its own
half-life so between isomeric
transitions they're usually very very
fast but once in a while they're not
like technetium-99 metastable to
technetium-99 has a half-life of around
six days which is why it's so useful as
a medical isotope so when you see
something marked m4 metastable all that
means is there some sort of a gamma also
known as an IT transition with a
particularly long half-life everyone
clear and what all that means
cool well there'll be some time for it
to sink in because with these
definitions in hand I want to pose a
problem to you guys let's say I start
off with some amount of an isotope N 1
and it decays by some mechanism we don't
care what two isotope n 2 and it decays
to some isotope n 3 with decay constants
lambda 1 and lambda 2 this is what we
call serial radioactive decay
how do we construct a system of
equations to tell us what is n1 as a
function of time what is n2 is a
function of time and what is n3 as a
function of time where do we begin in a
general sense okay so let's start with
n1 we kind of have an expression for n1
already but let's start out with a
differential equation so the form of all
of these equations for everything cereal
radioactive decay and burning isotopes
in a reactor and creating isotopes in a
reactor is going to take the following
form
the general equation is simple the
change equals creation - destruction or
the simple thing is let's say the the
change is a source - a sink and we'll
have to come up for every one of these
isotopes for a mathematical way to
describe what's the source and what's
the sink so if we want to measure the
change in n 1 as a function of time what
are the sources of isotope N 1 yeah no
sources we're starting off with some
fixed quantity of N 1 let's just call it
N 1 not but you're right there's no
continuous source of isotope N 1 what
about its destruction
yeah decay to n2 so we've got the
equation for that right there it depends
on the decay constant of number one and
the amount of number one so what we're
doing here I love how this course is
timed with 1803 because you're learning
ordinary differential equations in 1803
and we're gonna be solving order
ordinary differential equations for a
fair bit of this course so it's one of
those rare times and you get to like
learn math and put it to use at the same
time instead of six years later just
kind of nice so that's easy let's go to
the more challenging one what is the
source of isotope n to decay from n 1 so
how would I mathematically write that
just lambda 1 N 1 and what is the
destruction of isotope and and to anyone
else takes the same form it depends on
the decay constant of isotope 2 in the
amount of isotope two that's there
how about isotope 3 where does that come
from
that's it the source is lambda two and
two what are the sinks or the
destruction nothing so we have a rarely
very simple set of posed differential
equations to describe the production and
the destruction of these three isotopes
so let's imagine now that n1 was let's
say radium which exists all throughout
the soil and rocks and two is radon the
gas that's produced from radium decay
and then n3 could be let's say this one
of the stable daughter products of radon
so these are the sorts of calculations
that are done all the time in real life
to see if you know how much radians in
the rock how much radon do you expect to
breathe in because at the same time
you're producing radon from radium decay
and the radon is decaying itself so you
can't just say oh the activity of the
radium equals the amount of radon
because it's being created and destroyed
all at the same time and it depends on
how much there is around same thing with
nuclear activation analysis you'll let's
say you'd start off with sodium 21 you
can create sodium 22 sodium 22 will
decay by positron emission what comes
before sodium probably neon I think 22
that's my guess yeah so if you want to
say how much sodium 22 is there well
you're both creating it from sodium 21
from Neutron absorption and you're
decaying it naturally by positron
emission among other processes we're
gonna get back into how do we deal with
the neutrons thing probably on Tuesday
but for now let's work on solving this
system of equations so I think n1 is
pretty easy because we already have the
solution for it so I'll just write it
the harder one is end - so what can we
start by doing we've got an ordinary
differential equation with it's just
first order but there's two variables so
how do we deal
we do well we have other equations so
actually got this one yes
substitute n1 in here so we get
everything in terms of n2 and constants
in time so we'll rewrite this equation
as d + 2 DT which I'm also just going to
write as n 2 Prime I'm going to use this
little bit of notation that I'll leave
up there on the board because it's gonna
be a lot faster in writing which equals
lambda 1 and 10 e to the minus lambda 1
t minus lambda 2 and 2 can we separate
variables here I don't see an easy way
so 1803 experts how do we solve this
type of first-order differential
equations and I'll give you I'll won't
give you a hint I'll give you a little
bit of consolation no one from last year
knew how to approach this so if you
don't know I won't be disappointed
yep
mm-hmm Aadland the two and two to both
sides I think you're on to what I'm
thinking about also if you can't read
something I write please stop me and let
me know and I'll be happy to erase it I
don't think I've said that yet but it
takes a lot of control for me to get my
handwriting legible on the board let
alone on a piece of paper so if you
can't read please let me know okay so
now we've got the N twos separate from
the N ones what do we do next okay let's
try this assume n two has the form e to
the what negative has the form e to the
lambda negative 1t with an a some
constant in front what makes you say
that
mmm-hmm cool so that is one way to do it
it's gonna get a little messy though
there's another method specifically for
equations of the form let's call it Y
prime plus I'm gonna use notation they
may have used in 1803 I hear a couple of
AHA anything look familiar about this
type of equation okay what is it it's
not that hard anyone remember the word
integrating factor and it was probably
done horribly and unlike six math boards
or whatever so I'm gonna show you the
simpler way to do this the idea here is
we want to multiply everything by some
by something so I some function mu what
am you there put am you there put am you
there I think that's the notation that's
usually used in differential equations
such that this thing right here is
shrinkable through the product rule or
the product rule just I'm not assuming
everyone remembers says that let's say
you have some function a of T B of T
prime is like a prime times B plus a
times B prime so we're kind of getting
around to the method that Luke was
talking about but we're gonna do it via
a little bit of a cleaner way we
multiply every term by some function mu
such that this part is one of these
perfect product rules at which point we
can shrink and integrate the expression
without going through the derivation of
how integrating factors are done I'll
just let you know that this function mu
ends up being e to the integral of P
that is our integrating factor so that's
the end result of what was probably six
boards of 1803 am I am I right or am I
mistaken Wow things haven't changed in
15 years cool okay so what is mu for
this equation
luckily P of T is pretty simple
which part of this equation right here
is our P of T like term actually just
lambda two because we've got our
variable right here that right there is
our P of T so we'll just say that mu
equals e to the integral of ya of lambda
2 DT which is just e to the lambda 2 T
that's our integrating factor right
there so we'll multiply every term right
here by that
so we'll say e to the lambda 2 T times M
2 prime plus lambda 2 e to the lambda 2
T anyone see what's going on here
there's the product rule thing going on
times n 2 plus e to the lambda 2 T times
lambda 1 and 10 e to the minus lambda 1
T equals 0 and we have successfully
created something here that could be
shrunk up with a product rule yep
oh yeah there's an equal sign there
isn't it that's what tripped me up thank
you so there is indeed a minus sign
there because I skipped a step putting
everything on one side of the equation
yep where you replace one variable with
a or replace a couple of variables with
another one yeah there are there are
lots of ways of solving a first-order OD
II like this sure so this would work
with variation of parameters it would
work with what Luke's talking about it
works with this one this just happened
to be a particularly simple one because
the integrating factor is so simple so
let's cram this up right here
so this is like saying n 2 times e to
the lambda 2 T prime minus and we've got
2 e to the some things that we can
combine right here so I'll just say
lambda 1 and 10 e to the lambda 2 minus
lambda 1 T equals zero so now I will put
this term back on the other side by
doing that and now we just integrate
both sides and we get + 2 e to the
lambda 2 T equals let's see comes lambda
1 and 10 over lambda 2 minus lambda 1 e
to the lambda 2 minus lambda 1 T plus
some integration constant C and in this
case our initial condition well how much
of isotope n 2 did we start with have we
specified that yet no let's make it
simple
let's assume that the initial amount of
isotope n2 equals zero we put some
isotope in the reactor or started off
with some amount of isotope like radium
didn't start off with and it didn't
start off with any radon and just kept
going so then all we have to do is
divide each side by e to the lambda 2 T
and that cancels those that cancels that
and that and we end up with n 2 as a
function of time equals lambda 1 n 1
naught over lambda 2 minus lambda 1
times e to the minus lambda 1 T ok and
we've got an expression for n 2
how about n 3 do we even have to solve
this one see a couple people shaking
their heads no why is that well not
quite because we are we hope well yeah I
guess we've kind of solved it for n 1
but now we take this expression for n 2
stick it in here and then solve that
it's going to get messy so I'm going to
show you something
mathematically now that I'll show you
graphically later there's a conservation
equation that we're missing here if we
sum up isotopes n 1 + 2 + 3 equals what
conserving total number of atoms exactly
and 1 not in this situation where we
started off with some known quantity of
isotope 1 only you can't change the
number of atoms here you can only change
the type of atoms so we don't have to
solve for e 3 oh sorry for n 3 because n
3 is just N 1 not minus N 1 minus n 2
and that takes like an extra 10 minutes
out of the today's lecture so later on
when we have a projector on
Tuesday I will show you these equations
graphed out where I've actually I'll
share this with you did I tell you guys
about the decimals graphical calculator
or have I shown this to you yet go here
for all of your graphing needs it's free
and the best part that I like is at any
time you define some parameter it
automatically makes a slider bar so you
can play with the equations and you can
just say like well what if L 1 and L
lambda 1 and L 2 are equal what if they
were way different and it just graphs
the solutions for you it's pretty useful
so I'll show you some of that on Tuesday
when we actually have a screen let me
see what time it is
oh sweet we've got plenty of time so now
I want to pose the following questions
to you guys I'm going to erase stuff
from here because we still have some
space how do we model nuclear activation
analysis using this kind of equation
we'll start off with the same equation
so let's say we'll have a minus lambda 1
N 1 we'll have n 2 minus lambda 2 n 2
minus something 3 equals something let's
see there's a lambda 1 N 1
there's a lambda 2 n 2 minus something
I've left some trailing minus signs to
indicate that where you don't have
complete equations for this yet so for
the case of nuclear activation analysis
where we have some imposed flux flux of
neutrons
does anyone remember from some of our
previous flash-forwards how do we turn
these into creation and destruction
rates of these different isotopes yep
so let's say we are we've now stuck n 1
in the reactor and we're now using the
reactor to create different isotopes
like n 2 and n 3 but at the same time
they're in the reactor they're getting
cooked as well by some imposed flux of
neutrons how do we set up and not solve
the system of equations to describe this
they're getting destroyed and whatnot oh
that depends on the isotope so let's
define what the system that system is
let's say we stuck in some other isotope
and not and we put it in and we're gonna
have to say it's if we have n not prime
so minus some creation term and in this
case n naught can absorb a neutron to
become n one and one is decaying to n 2
and 2 is decaying to n 3 but also N 1
can be burned by neutrons and n 2 can be
burned by neutrons and n 3 can be burned
by neutrons so here I've given you kind
of a simplistic situation that doesn't
usually exist here I've given you a
situation that you can replicate in the
reactor how do we model this nuclear
activation analysis process well first
of all what's the creation rate of n-not
the stuff we put in the reactor are we
creating any
no Luke it could be so if we had this
fall the following nuclear reaction now
it's getting crazy we can model that too
let's do it okay I was gonna say no but
let's do it we can let so I'm what I'm
trying to do here is give you the
mathematical tools to model any real
physical situation usually in this class
like when I took it the discussion
stopped here we got to start looking at
different graphs of secular versus
transient equilibrium like in the
reading but I want you guys to have the
intuition to say all right let's take
any crazy decay diagram right and n 3
becomes n 1 let's just go nuts how do we
set up the differential equations for
this assuming that computers consultant
in every case whereas by long pointer go
back to this here the change is the
creation - the destruction so what are
all the creation sources in our new
scenario for n naught
well I'll pose you a simpler question if
there is no isotope n - can you create
any and not no because the only way to
make and not is to start with n - so we
know its creation term is gonna have an
N 2 in it what else does it depend on I
heard both of the pieces of the answer
correct at the same time it depends on
the flux of neutrons and it depends on
the cross section this macroscopic cross
section right here okay I'm sorry
no no it depends on the microscopic
cross section because we have an amount
of n - but it does depend on how many
neutrons you throw at it
and what is the probability that each of
those neutrons make some n not so what
we've got right here is a reaction rate
so who remembers from the like second or
third lecture we said a reaction rate
can be expressed like macroscopic cross
section times a flux which is the same
as a microscopic cross section times
number density times flux but this is
better known as a macroscopic cross
section member I kind of showed this to
you very briefly when we talked about
cross sections now is where we actually
use them so the cross sections like the
probability that a neutron coming in to
atom n is going to react with it the
macroscopic cross section in units of
let's say 1 over centimeters is the
total let's say the total probability
accounting for how many are there and
the flux is in neutrons per centimeter
squared per second combine these
together and you get a reaction rate in
atoms per centimeter cubed for a second
a volumetric reaction rate there we go
so n1 can be created let's give this
cross-section a designation from n2 to
n-not so let's call it cross-section to
0 how can n does not be destroyed
I'll give you a hint it looks very
similar to this term anyone want to take
a guess yeah we haven't specified that
I'm going to I'm gonna cut the craziness
it there I think but just look at the
reactions right here and not can absorb
a neutron and become n1 so how do we
mathematically write that minus the
cross-section of let's say zero going to
1 let's just call it that times the
neutron flux times what times the amount
that's there and not so this is your
destruction term using this pattern we
can fill in all the remaining terms for
all the remaining isotopes so what are
the creation mechanisms for isotope n1
well just follow the arrows mm-hmm yep
there's this one right here we can edit
this but flip the sign because it's
creation
so Sigma oh one flux and not and what
else can create n1 because we're just
going crazy today and three can create
and one because we said so but yeah cuz
we said so so now we'll say also will
have this cross-section for three
turning into one times flux times n 3
minus the decay of n1 using our activity
expression - what else
I heard some yep croc there will be the
cross-section of n1 let's call it going
to some isotope we don't care about
times the flux times n1 so as long as
you can draw a like arrow decay and
destruction reduction diagram we can put
this to meth that's the crazy thing
let's finish it up how about n2 we know
that n1 can decay to end - what are the
other production mechanisms for n2
follow the arrows that's it that's
because we're not changing anything at
this point what are all the destruction
mechanisms for n2 yep it can decay it
can be absorbed by a neutron to become
something we don't care about see let's
call it cross-section to know times flux
times n2 - the cross-section from 2 to 0
just this term with a minus sign
how about n3 what are all the ways we
can make n3 so you see it a little
louder only from decay again just see
what ours are pointing at it and what
about the destruction mechanisms friend
3 yep so there's some probability it
decays let's say cross-section 3 no
times flux times n3 - this arrow going
back to n1 running out of space too many
units from 3 to 1 flux and 3 so the
point of accepting the escalation of
this problem into something crazy is
that it doesn't matter how crazy it gets
as long as you have like an arrow based
diagram or a flowchart to say which
isotopes become which other isotopes by
which other means you can pose and
correctly write the set of equations
that define
them this is when I would bring in
MATLAB or Mathematica I could make you
do this analytically but this isn't a
course 18 class and yeah we don't go
there cool so I think I guess it's
probably getting towards 10 of 10 of
close enough it's like 3 of 10 of so I'd
like to open it up to any questions
because we let this I let this escalate
freely to prove the point that as long
as you know what decays into what or
what creates or destroys what you can
set up the equations correctly and what
we'll be doing on Tuesday is graphing
this where we can pose an arbitrarily
complex set of equations and you can
start looking at well the change in one
depends on the amount of the other and
you can almost graphically solve these
on paper
forget Mathematica or MATLAB if you look
at last year's exam I actually posed a
more complex set of beasts and said draw
the solution and I'm gonna we're going
to show you how to do that but any
question on how we formed these yep so
we just said let's say n 3 2 care to sum
the case that some isotope we don't care
about that's how I initially had it and
then I think Luke said well can n to
become n 0 and I said yeah sure so there
can be a cross section for every type of
reaction so in reality you might have
any reaction under the Sun right one
isotope could absorb a neutron and decay
by like any of three or four different
mechanisms into something else you may
have different probabilities for each of
these
yep
the only time I'd expect you to find
these decay constants is if I told you
what these isotopes were those are also
listed on the table of nuclides as and
they give you the half-life and you know
from this half-life relation what the
decay constant is if I didn't tell you
what these isotopes were I would just
have you keep these symbols as lambda 1
lambda 2 and I might pose a question
which will solve graphically on Tuesday
like let's say solve this set of
equations for lambda 2 is much greater
than lambda 1 I don't care what the
numbers are let's just look at that
general relation and all the graphs for
that sort of situation will follow the
same pattern cool any other questions on
how we constructed this set of
differential equations and know that
I'll never ask you to solve them
numerically or analytically yeah that's
why we have computers and this is the
future these I might expect you to know
how to derive but this is the simplest
possible case cool
all right if there's no questions and
let's take another 10-minute break and
I'll be here for recitation to go over
whatever problems you guys would like to
do
you